Redwood JS an opinionated full stack
JavaScript framework for building big
ambitious startups as we all know the
JavaScript ecosystem is incredibly
complex with millions of different tools
to choose from when architecting an app
Redwood takes a collection of the most
battle tested Technologies like react
Prisma graphql storybook and jest then
weaves them together so developers can
get things done quickly and reliably it
was developed by a team of software
Engineers that includes the co-founder
of GitHub and hit version 1.0 in 2022 it
has its own custom router for
server-side rendering but unlike many
other Frameworks it doesn't use the file
system and instead puts all routes in a
single file with automatic code
splitting for each page most importantly
though it provides abstractions to
connect your front-end UI to a back-end
relational database via a graphql API
its rails inspired CLI can quickly
generate the code required to build
complex features and not just build them
but also test them with jest and
storybook it ships with Apollo client by
default making it easy for the front end
to consume data from the graphql API and
when it comes time for deployment the
code can easily run on a standalone
server or your favorite serverless
infrastructure to get started generate a
new Redwood project with yarn the front
end code is managed in the web directory
it's a react app that's wrapped with the
Redwood provider with routes as the main
entry point for the UI the routes
component is a collection of URL
patterns that point to a specific
component which is defined in the Pages
directory all pages are automatically
imported here keeping your code nice and
concise in addition all pages are
automatically lazy loaded with code
splitting making your load times as fast
as possible it also contains a layout
system to share UI across different
routes now the back end is organized in
the API directory which uses Prisma to
manage the database schema but also
provides the tools required to build a
full-fledged graphql API to access your
data the back end can also Define its
own custom serverless functions or
directives which operate like middleware
to handle concerns like user
authentication what's really cool though
is Redwood provides an abstraction
called a cell to simplify complex data
fetching a cell is just a component that
manages a graphql query allowing you to
clearly Define different states like
loading error and success like angular
or rails Redwood provides strong
conventions and a CLI to generate the
boilerplate code for you use it to
quickly create a component page or cell
along with the code for jest and
storybook for testing and finally use
the CLI to deploy the app to your
favorite serverless Cloud platform this
has been Redwood JS in 100 seconds hit
the like button and subscribe if you
want to see more short videos like this
thanks for watching and I will see you
in the next one